all right we are asked to choose the
graph of the function and the function
is f of x is equal to 2 times 3 to the x
and we have three choices here so pause
this video and see if you can determine
which of these three graphs actually is
the graph of f of x
all right now let's work through this
together so whenever i have a function
like this which is an exponential
function because i'm taking some number
and i'm multiplying it by some num some
other number to some power so that tells
me that i'm dealing with an exponential
so i like to think about two things what
happens when x equals zero
what is what is the value of our
function
well when you just look at this function
this would be 2 times
3 to the 0
which is equal to 3 to the 0 is 1 it's
equal to 2.
so one way to think about it in the
graph of y is equal to f of x
when x is equal to 0 y is equal to 2. or
another way to think about it is this
value in an exponential function
sometimes called the initial value if
you were thinking of the x-axis instead
of the x-axis we're thinking about the
time axis or the t-axis that's why it's
sometimes called the initial value
but the y-intercept is going to be
described by that when you have a
function of this form and you saw it
right over there f of 0 3 to the 0 is 1
you're just left with the 2. so which of
these have a y-intercept of 2
well here the y-intercept looks like 1.
here the y-intercept looks like 3 here
the y-intercept is 2.
so just through elimination through that
alone we can feel pretty good that the
third graph is probably the choice
but let's keep analyzing it to feel even
better about it and so that we have the
skills for really any exponential
function that we might run into
well the other thing to realize
this number 3 is often referred to as a
common ratio and that's because every
time you increase x by 1 you're going to
be taking 3 to a 1 higher power or
you're essentially going to be
multiplying by 3 again so for example f
of 1 is going to be equal to 2 times 3
to the 1. 2 times 3 to the 1 or 2 times
3 which is equal to 6. so from f of 0 to
f of 1 you essentially had to multiply
by 3. and you keep multiplying by 3. f 2
f of 2 you're going to multiply by 3
again it's going to be 2 times 3 squared
which is equal to 18 and so once again
when i increased my x by 1 i'm
multiplying the value of my function
by 3. so let's just see which of these
do this this one we said it has the
wrong y-intercept but as we go from
x equals 0 to x equals 1 we are going
from 1 to 3
and then we are going from 3 till
looks like we're closed pretty close to
nine so it does look like this does have
a common ratio of three just has a
different y-intercept than the function
we care about this looks like the graph
f of x is equal to just one times three
to the x
here we're starting at 3
and then when x equals 1 it looks like
we are doubling
every time
x increases by 1. so this looks like the
graph of
y is equal to i have my what we could
call our initial value or our
y-intercept three and if we're doubling
every time we increase by one three
times two to the x that's this graph
here as i said this first graph looks
like y is equal to 1
times
3 to the x we are tripling every time 1
times 3 to the x or we could just say y
is equal to 3 to the x
now this one here better work because we
already picked it as our solution so
let's see if that's actually the case so
as we increase by one we should multiply
by three so two times three is indeed
six
and then when you increase by another
one we should go to 18 and that's kind
of off the charts here but it does seem
reasonable to see that we are
multiplying by three every time
and you could also go the other way if
you're going down by one you should be
dividing by three so two divided by
three this does look pretty close to
two-thirds
so we should feel very good about our
third choice